اهلا بك احمد اهلا بفاطمه وبالمشاهدين
بدون شك ما يراهن عليه اردوغان ما يعتبره
شبه نصر حققه في الجوله الاولى من
الانتخابات ان كان في الرئاسيات ولو لم
يظفر بخمسين زائدا واحدا او في
البرلمانيات التي فازت فيها الموالاه يعول
على الاسبوعين المتبقيين قبل جوله الاعاده
التي تشهدها تركيا للمره الاولى في
تاريخها دعني انقل لك بعض يعني مما تقوله
الصحف هذا الصباح من المواليه والمعارضه
لاضعك ايضا في صوره النقاش الحاد الدائر
بين الطرفين في هذه الصبيحه صحيفه صباح
المواليه تقول المواطن صوت للانجازات وليس
للثرثره وهكذا سيقرر في جوله الاعاده
حريات تقول تعرفنا على جوله الاعاده لاول
مره في تاريخ ديمقراطيتنا تركيا المواليه
تقول هزيمه الطاوله السداسيه في اشاره الى
المعارضه صحيفه اكشام المواليه الفائز هو
الديمقراطيه التركيه اما يصحف المعارضه
مثل جمهوريه فقالت سنفوز مع علامه تعجب
اما صحيفه سوزو فكانت اكثر قسوه على
الموالاه وعلى بعض الناخبين من الذين
صوتوا للموالاه قالت يبدو ان الشعب شبعان
شبعان احمد باللغه التركيه تعني توك
والسياره التي انتجتها تركيا بصناعه محليه
وهي حديثه تعني ولكن بالغين وليس بالكاف
هنا تحاول سوزو والمعارضه الاستهزاء
باستخدام كلمه وهناك هجوم في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي من قبل الموالات على
هذه التعابير التي تستخدمها المعارضه
وكانه استهزاء بالانجازات التركيه طبعا
صحيفه قرار المعارضه ايضا قالت امامنا
اسبوعان طويلان اما ياني تشاك القوميه
المعار تقول الاعين تترقب قرار القوميين
واوجان اما بالنسبه الى السوشيال ميديا
وتويتر فيتصدر لا يزال يتصدر سنان اوغان
الذي ينتظر قراره بعدما بدا المفاوضات مع
الجانبين لمن سيدعم اضافه الى رئيس حزب
الظفر حليف سنان اوغان في تحالف الاجداد
ولكن يعني 240 الفا يتصدر سنان اوغام على
تويتر
تخيل انه لم يستطع رغم انه حليف سنان
اوغان الذي تدور كل الاحاديث عنه الان لم
يستطع ان يظفر وهو رئيس حزب الظفر بمقعد
في البرلمان لان النسبه التي تحصل عليها
هي
2.23% وهو دون العتبه الانتخابيه اللازمه
اي سبعه بالمئه كان قال اعتذر من الشعب
لعدم تمكننا من تحقيق حلمه بدخول البرلمان
واعاده اللاجئين السوريين انظر الى كل هذه
الملفات واختلاطها في التص وعناوين الصحف
والسوشيال ميديا في تركيا هذا الصباح
في هذه الصحف طاهر يعني هو يجسد حقيقه مدى
التوتر ومدى التنافس الشديد بين الاطراف
المترشحه لهذه الانتخابات لكن طاهر ايضا
منذ الاعلان عن نتائج الاوليه وهناك حاله
يتحدث عنها عن عدم رضا او حاله خيبه امل
لدى جانب المعارضه في سواء على الصعيد
المناصرين او على صعيد القيادات ايضا ربما
انعكس ذلك على في مساله اقاله او استقاله
نائب اوغلو هل اقيل او استقال وما حقيقه
الخلافات بينهما اذا توفرت معلومات حول
ذلك
الواضح مما حصل انه تمت اقالته من قبل
رئيس
مرشح تحالف الامه رئيس حزب رئيس حزب الشعب
الجمهوري
كمال كليتش بسبب ادائه الضعيف في هذه
الانتخابات وهو كان مسؤول بشكل مباشر عن
يعني الاتصالات والاعلام والعلاقات العامه
وبالتالي كان يعني يراهن عليه في هذه
المعركه حاميه الوطيس التي حصلت بدون شك
ربما يعني الكل كل الانظار تتجه الان الى
قادم الايام لنرى اذا ما كان سيحصل تصدعات
اكبر في المعارضه او او في الجهه الاخرى
ولكن بما ان الجهه الاخرى فازت في
البرلمان حتى الان ولو ان المقاعد قد
تتقلص بحكم بعض الانسحابات من التحالف
الرئاسي
فاذا التصدعات قد تحصل الاستقالات في
محاوله لتحسين موقعها لتحسين شروطه في هذه
المعركه ولكن هل ستكون ايام المقبله في
فتره اسبوعين فقط قادره على ان يكسب فيها
ما خسره في كل الفتره الماضيه خلال الحمله
الانتخابيه والنتائج التي حققها هذا
السؤال كبير هناك
طريق في هذه النتائج
لفاطمه فاطمه اهلا بك كيف تبدو اذا اجواء
الاستعدادات للجوله الثانيه في انقره
تعدادات احمد اهلا بك وبطاهر والمشاهدين
كما نرى هنا خلفي يعني بدانا نرى معالم
الحملات الانتخابيه مجددا تتعلق على
الشوارع بدانا نرى الحملات الاعلانيه
اللوح الدعائيه ايضا تعود الى شوارع
العاصمه انقره اليوم من المتوقع ان يعلن
كريستار اوغلو عن استراتيجيته للحمله
الانتخابيه في دورتها الثانيه وايضا نتوقع
ان نسمع من محرم ان جيبنا ايضا كلمه له
وخطابا يدعم فيه كليش دار محرم انجي الذي
قال بانه مهما حصل يجب ان تذهب هذه
الحكومه الحاليه اذا هذه من الاخبار
المتوقعه اليوم ان نشهدها في العاصمه
بالنسبه للانتقال للجوله الثانيه احمد
يعني هناك كما تعلم شروط خمسه شروط لسنان
اوغان يطرحها على المرشحين لكي يكسب او
لكي يدلي باصواته لهم طبعا من هذه الشروط
ان تثبيت المواد الاربعه الاولى من
الدستور وضع حد ضد محاوله ازاله القوميه
من الدستور وهو ما تنص عليه الماده 66 على
فكره ويشترط ايضا ترحيل 13 مليون اللاجئ
السوري من تركيا كما يزعم هو رغم ان هذا
الرقم حقيقه غير منطقي ويريد التخلص من
نسبه الفائده المرتفعه والتضخم وهذا الكرت
الذي يضغط به على الحزب الحاكم ويريد
الفصل بين المنظمات الارهابيه وهياكلها
السياسيه الجدير بالذكر هنا احمد ان
اردوغان بالفعل يعمل الان على هذه الشروط
يعني هو ينوي تغيير الدستور كما قال قبل
عام ومازال يكررها وهو ايضا بدا بالتطبيع
مع دمشق كما راينا من اجل من اعاده
اللاجئين الى سوريا وايضا بدا خطوه فعليه
لاغلاق حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي ويعني يرى
بعض الخبراء هنا في الداخل التركي احمد
بانم المشهد السياسي التركي او ان سنان
اوغان والخمسه في المئه او 5% اكثر بقليل
من اصواتهم لن تؤثر حقيقه كثيرا في
الاصوات لانه لانه يرون بانه نصف هذه
الاصوات يا اما لن تتجاوب مع اعتنان اوغلو
ان اختار احد المرشحين او لن يذهبوا الى
الانتخابات كليا اذا يعني
بعكس ما هو يعتقد يعني يرون المحللين بان
الاصوات التي تنتمي له لن تؤثر حقيقه في
الجوله الثانيه وفي الناخبين
اذا سكتفي بهذا القدر يكون معكم في متابعه
دائما للتطورات الانتخابات في تركيا شكرا
لك من انقره كنتم على العربيه فاطمه فهد
العربيه طاهر بركه تحياتي طاهر وفاطمه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات